we will move on and we'll tell you about
North Korea because its leader says the
latest missile launches were a way to
test the ability of its nuclear weapons
to wipe out American and South Korean
targets Kim Jong-un also acknowledged
plans to conduct more tests Kim said the
launches were in response to Joint Naval
drills between the U.S and South Korea
Rob McBride has more from Seoul
the North Koreans have said very little
about this flurry of Miss ballistic
missile activity that's gone on pretty
uh much on unchecked for two weeks
continual launching of these missiles
the last week of September the first
week of October and then today Monday
the official North Korean news agency
comes out with almost a pronouncement a
long Declaration of exactly what it's
been doing the dates of the tests the
types of missiles being launched and
tested with photographs showing Kim
Jong-un the North Korean leader
overseeing all of these tests and
basically the headline to come away from
this is that the North Koreans say that
all that they have been doing is
carrying out what they call tactical
Nuclear drills this is the supposed
development of a smaller tactical
Nuclear devices now these are the the
kind of miniaturized nuclear warheads
that you would put onto a rocket or a
short-range ballistic missile it it does
require an awful lot of a technical
advancement of technology and
technological know-how in order to do
this and it's unclear just how advanced
the North Koreans are in developing
tactical nuclear warheads but certainly
they are working on the delivery systems
for these types of warheads they've also
as well as carrying out a shorter range
ballistic missiles probably the most
serious development over the past couple
of weeks was last last week on October
the 4th they launched an intermediate
range ballistic missile right over the
top of Japan that landed in the Pacific
Ocean that caused obvious alarm from all
of North Korea's neighbors it's the
first time they've carried out such a
launch like that in five years and the
North Koreans say that that is a new
type of missile they also say that they
have been practicing and developing the
technology to have um to have explosions
in the air above the ground now that's
the kind of delivery that you would use
if you were launching a nuclear device
so as uh Rob was just saying Kim Jong-un
made acquiring tactical nuclear weapons
a top priority at a key party Congress
in January last year tactical nuclear
weapons are different from long-range
strategic nuclear weapons as they can be
used over short distances they can be
deployed in many different ways and even
fired as artillery shells on
battlefields the size and power of these
weapons can vary from less than one
kiloton to 100 kilotons by comparison
the atomic bomb drops on Hiroshima in
the second world war was 15 kilotons
North Korea revised its nuclear Doctrine
last month this law includes using
preemptive nuclear strikes to protect
itself if an enemy Nations tries to
remove Kim Jong-un from power and Kim
has declared the north an irreversible
nuclear power let's speak to Leonard
Petrov who's a North Korea specialist
and a visiting fellow at the Australian
National University College of Asia and
Pacific he's in Sydney and he's joining
us live welcome to Al Jazeera why would
tactical weapons be a priority for North
Korea now
well the Korean Peninsula has been at
war was for the last 70 plus years since
North Korea tried to unify the peninsula
by force and found itself on the counter
attack
um well and back then even Soviet Union
or China would not even think about
sharing nuclear technology with uh with
the king's regime but these days the
indigenous nuclear technology which Kim
Jong-un has inherited from his father
and grandfather became the trump card
for the regime survival and
um looking at what is happening in
Ukraine
looking at what Moscow is threatening
the world these days North Korea has
shifted quickly shifted its threats from
strategic or long-range
missiles and weapons of mass destruction
which potentially May Target the far
away countries two is something more
nearby uh threats with tactical weapons
because North Korea and actually uh
developing these tactical nuclear
weapons
well the nuclear weapons would use the
same technology and the production of uh
highly uh enriched uranium or processed
plutonium but the yield delivered by the
device would be much smaller and and of
course the size of the uh Warhead or a
bomb is going to be smaller which can be
mounted not only in a rocket even if
it's a short range missile but can be
also dropped from the airplane uh
brought closer to the front line on the
truck
or brought by a submarine and and
detonated somewhere in near the coastal
line
actually resorted to to using them
well the problem with practical nuclear
weapon is that it's going to affect the
launching country as much as the
um also the destination land or the
enemy because it depends on the
direction of the wind
um also how tested technology is and
North Korea hasn't tested its nuclear
devices for the last five years and the
most recent test was a hydrogen bomb uh
the thermonuclear weapon which was much
more powerful and certainly it would be
a suicidal
attempt to use that type of weapon so
that's why Kim Jong-un is much more
focused now on something of a more
Precision strike with a low yield
delivery with Potential Threat to be
delivered not only to the enemies from
far away but from nearby and South Korea
is still a place which is where 38
000 U.S troops are stage patient and
also the right us Allied countries have
their assets around the Korean Peninsula
as well which may be
destroyed or defeated just at once thank
you so much for speaking to us from
Sydney